حنون من هان طلع الطرق طلع الشوارع طلع
البيوت بيوت بيوتنا ولا انا بنت البلد ولا
حاجه عارفه عن البلد ولا عارفه هذه دار
مين من دار مين من دار مين بهدلونا هم ايش
عملنا احنا ايش سوينا اخذنا اسرا لهم طب
ما هم با اسرانا موتوهم في السجون مين دور
عليهم مين دور عليهم بقول لك احنا مقاومه
بدنا نضل نقاوم لاخر يوم في عمرنا والاجنه
بده يموت الناس في اجنه في البطون في اجنه
كل جيل هيطلع احقد على الجيل الاب قبله ما
يفكر انه خلص ولا حماس بتخلص ولا فتح
بتخلص ولا الجهاد بتخلص ولا اي فصيل بيخلص
ايش ما يعملوا ايش ما يدمره ع الفاضي على
الفاضي القصه مش قصه حماس القصه قصه
فلسطين وين ارضنا اعطونا ارضنا اعطونا
ارضنا وعيشوا بسلام عيشوا بسلام واحتفلوا
زي ما بتحتفل احتفلوا انت واحنا بنحتفل
اما انت تحتفل واحنا اسرانا في السجون
حسبنا الله عليكم ونعم الوكيل وعلى كل من
هي وليكم طير ابابيل على اسرائيل طير
ابابيل عليكم يا رب وكل من يا رب يكون
معاكم حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل